j'ai eu le privilège de présider le
comité de gouvernance de cette
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
qui a commencé ses travaux le 9 décembre
et qui les a terminé le 3 avril donc
c'est 9 weekends dans tout 27 jours de
travail qui ont permis d'aboutir à la
production citoyenne dont vous allez
prendre connaissance peu de temps après
puisque les citoyens membres de la
Convention vous en diront quelques mots
alors comment ça s'est passé donc le
comité de gouvernance notre mission a
été de de fixer le cadre méthodologique
du travail de la convention de définir
les grands enfin de faire les grands
arbitrages et de définir le calendrier
de travail donc on a tout de suite
décidé d'avoir
185 citoyens alors pour être honnête
avec vous on avait décidé d'avoir plus
de citoyens que pour la convention
climat il y avait 150 citoyens à
l'époque nous on voulait qu'il y ait au
moins 150 citoyens aussi mais
contrairement à la Convention climat on
voulait que ceux qui terminent et
commencer et donc par peur de d'une
perte en ligne disons vu que c'est quand
même très très lourd on a décidé d'en
tirer au sort 170
l'organisme en charge du tirage au sort
nous a dit si vous en voulez 170 le 9
décembre il faut que vous en ayez 185 le
2 décembre et ben en fait il y en avait
185 de décembre 185 le 9 décembre et 184
à la fin ce qui
atteste
d'une d'une
merci
ce qui atteste quand même d'une volonté
très très forte de la part de ses
citoyens de ses citoyens de se saisir
d'une question difficile complexe et moi
je j'ai été là à chaque fois et je peux
vraiment
témoigner devant vous de la rigueur de
l'exigence de l'intelligence collective
dont c'est 184 citoyens on fait preuve
donc 194 citoyens
représentatif de la diversité de la
population française donc des hommes des
femmes des jeunes des moins jeunes
toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles tous les niveaux
de diplôme qui ont toutes les origines
géographiques qui ont travaillé sur une
question difficile à savoir je vous je
vous rappelle la question qui nous a été
posée par la première ministre le cadre
d'accompagnement de la fin de vie est-il
adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient-ils être introduit ça c'est la
question générale et donc pour organiser
la convention le la première ministre a
saisi le CESU donc le Conseil économique
social et environnemental dont je suis
membre et donc voilà donc c'est comme ça
que les travaux ont commencé alors sur
le déroulé je vous le disais c'est 9
weekends du vendredi au dimanche
en quatre mois donc c'est quand même
très très soutenu et puis vous le diront
mais le lundi est retourné au boulot
donc c'est vraiment un engagement très
très important de leur part 9 weekends
trois phases une première phase qu'on a
appelé appropriation et rencontre durant
laquelle les citoyens les citoyens ont
découvert le CESU ont découvert la
question posée par la première ministre
ce sont rencontrés ont échangé entre eux
on leur a aussi surtout dit pourquoi ils
étaient là et pourquoi ils n'étaient pas
là donc ça c'était très important
autrement dit il y a jamais eu
d'ambiguïté dans le cadre de cette
convention à aucun moment on a dit aux
citoyens qu'ils étaient là pour faire
une loi c'est pas la raison pour
laquelle ils ont été réunis en revanche
la conviction qu'on a au CESE et je
crois que cette convention le montre
bien c'est que pour certains sujets à
certains moments c'est important de
faire appel à des personnes qui ne
représentent que même une certaine
manière pour ressortir des espaces de
représentation d'intérêt classique et
puis leur demander d'aider à construire
la décision qui sera bel et bien prise
par les gens ont été élus pour ça donc
les parlementaires le gouvernement etc
le président de l'Afrique le
gouvernement etc donc voilà donc il y a
pas il y a jamais eu d'ambiguïté
là-dessus pas de pas de sans filtre en
gros donc chacun son travail mais
l'enjeu c'était bien d'avoir une
contribution citoyenne à un débat
national sur la fin de vie qui a été
ouvert en septembre dernier si je dois
le marquer par une date par la vie du
Comité consultatif national d'éthique
qui pour la première fois ouvre la porte
à une éventuelle aide active à mourir
donc première phase appropriation et
rencontre sur deux weekends ensuite
deuxième phase de délibération pour
notamment poser la controverse donc
autour de la dactive à mourir notamment
mais les citoyens citoyennes ils
reviendront sur ce point et puis une
troisième phase de pardon
d'harmonisation et de restitution
puisque produire un texte à 184 c'est
quand même un exercice
difficile voilà mais ça il vous le
diront donc qu'est-ce qui nous a guidé
dans la conduite de ces travaux
[Musique]
le parti pris qu'on a eu tout de suite
en tant que comité de gouvernance c'est
de se dire que le consensus n'était pas
comment dire n'était pas il était pas
impératif d'atteindre le consensus si
c'était le cas tant mieux mais si ce
n'était pas le cas tant pis et que sur
la question de la fin de vie il y avait
évidemment une partie qui était
transversale
s'il vous plaît merci et une partie qui
était transversale dont les citoyens
vous parleront en suite et qui est
plutôt consensuel qu'on appelle le quoi
qu'il en soit mais il y a une partie de
controverse autour notamment de l'aide
activa mourir et donc l'enjeu a bien été
pour éclairer la décision publique pour
éclairer les décideurs vous notamment et
bien été de d'expliquer la controverse
autour de la question de la dactive à
mourir et donc de poser à la fois les
points de convergence mais aussi les
points de divergence sans faire comme
s'il n'existait pas et ça c'est très
important puisque dans la réponse des
citoyens la question de la dactive à
mourir 75% d'entre eux se sont prononcés
en faveur 25% d'entre eux se sont
prononcés contre mais il y a pas de de
rapport minoritaire il y a un seul
rapport une seule production de la
attention puisque on a bien voulu
produire un texte qui mettait en miroir
à la fois les arguments en faveur les
arguments en défaveur et puis surtout
montrer la complexité et la nuance même
si on dit qu'on est pour la d'activent
avoir ça veut pas dire grand chose en
réalité et c'est bien pour ça qu'on fait
une convention citoyenne et qu'on se
contente pas dans sondage et qu'il faut
poser précisément ce que ça signifie les
critères enfin quelle forme quels
critères pour qui comment etc et là on
voit bien que vous avez pas uneanimité
évidemment
ni des positions évidentes donc voilà
nous c'est ce qui nous a semblé vraiment
essentiel c'est de revendiquer à la fois
la complexité de revendiquer la nuance
et de montrer que
même si la nuance existe ça n'empêche
pas d'aboutir à une majorité qui se
dégage sans alimenter ni les
polarisations ni les humiliations moi ce
qui m'a semblé important quand j'ai pris
la présidence de ce comité de
gouvernance je me suis dit bon il y
avait plein de raisons il y a plein de
choses que je me suis dit par ailleurs
sur comment je pourrais on pourrait
évaluer le succès au nom de cette
convention mais un des points qui me
semblait très important c'est qu'en
sortant pas des humiliations des
polarisations des points de vue qui ne
se sent pas ni considérés ni représentés
et je vous donne je vous partage cette
anecdote parce qu'elle est assez
parlante le dernier
jour juste avant que les citoyens votent
leur livrables l'une d'entre eux a pris
la parole et qui était plutôt dans la
partie des minoritaires on va dire après
la parole et a dit voilà je voudrais
remercier les 75% d'entre vous d'avoir
laissé 20 à 25% d'entre nous 5 ans 50%
du temps de parole et 50% de la place
dans le livrable et ça je trouve que
c'est quand même très important de de le
souligner parce que encore une fois et
après bon je répondrai à vos questions
mais encore une fois le l'exercice
démocratique auquel on a assisté pendant
ces quatre mois c'est un modèle vraiment
c'est absolument exemplaire beaucoup
d'écoute quand les gens interviennent il
y a une écoute quand même assez forte
une considération de tous les points de
vue ça aussi le le souci de ne pas
imposer quelque chose sur 70 c'est un
sujet qui est à la fois parfait pour une
convention mais en même temps qui peut
être pardonnez-moi l'expression mais
hyper casse gueule en fait et donc ça
n'a pas été le cas parce que il y a eu
vraiment ce souci de se respecter et de
ne pas dire à l'autre qu'il avait tort
et que la personne enfin qui a pas
certains n'ont pas tort et d'autres
n'ont pas raison c'est pas ça le sujet
le sujet c'est comment est-ce que
s'ennuyer les individualités sans y est
l'intime puisque c'est une question
évidemment intime on arrive à construire
un cadre collectif qui va pouvoir
éclairer la décision publique et
potentiellement faire chemine la société
vers quelque chose de différent a priori
voilà pour mon propos liminaire mais je
vous laisse poursuivre maintenant nous
allons vous laisser la parole vous dire
comment vous vous avez vécu cette
convention citoyenne
bonjour
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs donc le sujet de la fin de vie
a réuni comme La Vie Claire torie 184
citoyens qui ont été tirés au sort pour
répondre à la question posée par madame
la Première ministre
Elisabeth borne le cadre de
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie est-il
adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient-elles devraient-ils être
introduit pardonnez-moi c'est à cette
question que nous citoyens avons répondu
lors de débats approfondi et respectueux
pour construire justement du dialogue
sur ce sujet complexe qui touche à la
fois à l'intime et au collectif
la convention citoyenne qui nous a réuni
c'est un exercice de démocratie
participative qui permet de redonner la
parole aux citoyens dans le souci
d'enrichir le débat public améliorer la
qualité la légitimité des décisions et
ce afin de mieux répondre aux attentes
de la population donc pour accomplir ces
travaux et comprendre les enjeux qui en
sont liés nous avons rencontré un nombre
important de spécialistes du sujet
environ une soixantaine ce qui nous a
permis ensuite de débattre de manière
éclairée
le dialogue a permis d'esquisser des
perspectives des propositions communes
en prenant en compte le vécu et les
différentes sensibilités exprimées au
sein de la société française ces travaux
menés dans le cadre de la convention
citoyenne peuvent éclairer les pouvoirs
publics et nourrir la législation future
donc les citoyens ont répondu à 97% que
le cadre d'accompagnement de la fin de
vie doit être améliorée et à 82 % qu'il
n'est pas adapté aux différentes
situations rencontrées la conviction
commune est de renforcer d'améliorer
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie car à
ce jour on constate une inégalité
d'accès et une absence de réponse
satisfaisante pour certaines situations
de fin de vie
plusieurs propositions collectives ont
été adoptées à plus de 80%. le respect
du choix et de la volonté du patient
l'information grand public le
renforcement de la formation des
professionnels de santé
garantir les budgets nécessaires et
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
développer l'accompagnement à domicile
garantir un accès aux soins palliatifs
pour tous et sur l'ensemble du
territoire assuré une égalité d'accès et
améliorer l'organisation du parcours de
soins de la fin de vie
cette réflexion commune
issue de la démocratie participative a
mis en exergue la nécessité de
développer la culture palliative et les
soins palliatifs dans une société plus
solidaire tout en octroyant des droits à
ceux qui le demandent concernant leur
fin de vie notre travail à vocation à
alimenter la réflexion des pouvoirs
publics en esquissant des propositions
qui pourraient peut-être être le modèle
français de l'aide active à mourir je
laisse la parole à trois autres
conventionnelles Nathalie B Antonin D
qui représentera le point de vue des
universalistes et Micha qui est opposé à
l'aide active à mourir je vous remercie
si vous pouvez avant qu'on continue
rappeler comment comment vous avez été
choisi
désigner
clairement de façon très précise très
bien je vais le faire si c'est ok pour
toi
nous avons en fait été tirés au sort à
partir des numéros de téléphone
85% à partir des téléphones portables
15% à partir des téléphones fixes une
société nous a appelé il y a eu un
premier tour on va dire 3000 appels des
gens ont répondu ou pas enfin
imaginez-vous recevons à 20h un coup de
fil en général on pense qu'on veut nous
vendre des fenêtres donc il y a pas mal
exactement donc il y a eu pas mal de
gens qui ont fait ça et donc ensuite il
y a eu 2000 personnes qui ont été qui
ont accepté et puis il y a eu un certain
nombre de critères qui étaient
nécessaires pour justement montrer la
diversité de la population évidemment le
genre l'âge la localisation géographique
les CSP
la le niveau d'études et puis il y en
avait un cinquième non c'était tout 5
pardon et ces cinq critères ont permis
ensuite à partir des 2000 de ressortir
citoyens et citoyennes
c'est moi
donc madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les membres de la commission
des affaires sociales je vais présenter
donc la partie aide active à mourir qui
a été le sujet central pendant les
débats de la convention citoyenne dans
le rapport que vous avez certainement
lui il y a un nuancier de trois opinions
qui a émergé pendant ces débats et je
vais donc vous brosser rapidement le
premier sur l'accès à l'aide active à
mourir sous conditions on verra qu'il y
en a un autre il y a un autre modèle la
convention citoyenne c'est positionnée
majoritairement à 75% en faveur de
l'aide active à mourir dans le rapport
vous pouvez aussi qu'il y a quatre
modèles des modèles avec du suicide
assisté et euthanasie au choix suicide
assisté ou euthanasie par exception
suicide assister seul euthanasie seul le
modèle suicide assisté euthanasie au
choix et celui qui a remporté 40% des
suff
je rappelle les principaux arguments en
faveur de l'aide active à mourir que
nous avons
mis dans le dans le rapport premièrement
un cadre d'accompagnement actuel qui ne
répond pas à certaines situations de
souffrance comme les situations de
souffrance réfractaires tant physique
que psychique pour ne prendre que cet
exemple de les soins palliatifs sont
complémentaires mais ne répondent pas
toutes les situations des personnes en
fin de vie même avec le développement
des soins palliatifs resteront ces
quelques personnes dans les souffrances
sont inapaisables et qui souhaitent en
être soulagés troisième point l'aide
d'activer à mourir vient combler les
limites de la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès qui vous le
savez ne peut s'appliquer que sur une
courbe période de la fin de vie car les
médicaments utilisés ont un effet limité
dans le temps or certaines agonies
durent plusieurs jours voire dépasse la
semaine ce sont ces patients donc on
conseille d'État parle quand il écrit
qu'il n'en finissent pas de mourir pour
lesquels nous pensons que les actives à
mourir pourrait être une solution les
natives à mourir réduit ce temps de
l'agonie sous l'agent celles et ceux qui
l'ont choisi la famille dans certaines
situations les soignants
autre point quatrième lettre active à
mourir mais fin aux situations
d'hypocrisie car l'euthanasie passive où
illégale quelle que soit la façon qu'on
la nomme existe la mettre en oeuvre
l'aide activa mourir c'est faire rentrer
dans le droit à une réalité c'est éviter
l'hypocrisie et protéger le corps
médical cinquième point les d'activer à
mourir respectent la liberté de choix
des individus en offrant la possibilité
de préparer sa mort dans un cadre
sécurisé et de pouvoir inclure ses
proches dans le processus de fin de vie
elle permet aux personnes de décider des
conditions de leur fin de vie et de
choisir l'état de l'image qu'elle
souhaite laisser d'elle-même à leur
entourage au moment de leur mort sixième
point l'aide active à mourir permet une
fin de vie accompagnée et est un gage de
fraternité de solidarité c'est un moment
choisi et un moment accompagné légaliser
la haine pourrait transformer notre
rapport à la mort car on organisant
soi-même son départ le deuil de ses
proches pourrait être vécu différemment
et mieux accepter cela permettrait
d'éviter également des suicides violents
c'est proposer une mort solidaire au
lieu d'une mort solitaire nos
propositions s'appuient sur des critères
d'éligibilité
sur lesquels nous pourrons revenir si
vous le souhaitez la majorité de la
convention citoyenne s'accorde sur la
nécessité d'un parcours d'accès à la M
incluant conditions d'accès garde-fous
et mécanismes de contrôle c'est très
important pour nous le préalable à tout
accès de l'aide d'active à mourir et
évidemment la volonté du patient qui
doit être respectée dans le droit fil de
la loi 2002 sur les droits des patients
les étapes de ce parcours d'accès à la
haine sont au nombre de 5 une expression
de la demande libre éclairée et
révocable à tout moment un
accompagnement médical et psychologique
complet une évaluation du discernement
une validation de l'entrée de dans le
parcours d'aide active à mourir soumise
à une procédure collégiale et
pluridisciplinaire une réalisation de
l'acte encadré par le corps médical
l'aide médicale à mourir et la
contrepartie de notre médecine puissante
et comme le rappelle le professeur
régisse Aubry soigné n'est pas imposé
ses convictions mais respecter celles
des autres je conclurai en disant que le
dispositif convention citoyenne je
répondrai votre question de tout à
l'heure madame la Présidente et pour moi
vraiment un dispositif absolument
formidable au service de la démocratie
l'utiliser localement au niveau des
régions ou nationalement sera un moyen
de redonner de la confiance dans nos
institutions en intég rant concrètement
les citoyens et les citoyens dans les
processus délibératifs merci de votre
attention
continuez est-ce que dans ce panel il y
avait des personnes qui qui
appartiennent à l'Association pour le
droit de mourir d'indemnité
alors c'était pas un critère et en fait
sur les critères qui ont été posés comme
le disait Nathalie c'est vraiment des
critères de base en vraiment pour avoir
une forme de diversité de la population
française on a choisi on a choisi de
Next cœur ni les patients ni par mon ni
les soignants ni les personnes
confrontées à une situation de fin de
vie récente ni les militants voilà après
sur le sur le le collectif il y a
personne qui s'est présenté comme un
militant de la l'association pour droit
à mourir dans la dignité ni comme un
militant d'une association contre contre
la dactive à mourir c'est pas voilà
charbon de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat nous venons d'entendre
la présentation de la première option
des dactives à mourir qui est
conditionnée à un certain nombre de
critères je représente aujourd'hui le
groupe d'opinions des universalistes
pour nous le libre arbitre du sujet à
disposer de lui-même et ce qui fait foi
en effet la volonté de la personne doit
être respectée et elle prime quoi qu'il
arrive nous prenons un accès universel à
l'aide activa mourir il s'agit d'ouvrir
le suicide assisté et le l'euthanasie à
toute personne exprimant la volonté de
ne plus vivre et démontrant un
discernement direct et continue dans
notre approche toute demande déclenche
un parcours d'accompagnement spécifique
et individualisé adapté à la temporalité
de la situation et dont la vie est
consultatif
ce parcours pluridisciplinaire intègre
de nombreuses étapes qui constituent
autant de garde-fous permettant
d'encadrer l'accès à l'aide actif à
mourir la personne peut se rétracter à
tout moment à chaque étape du parcours
le caractère révocable de la demande
doit être rappelé de façon neutre et
sans volonté d'influencer la personne
les solutions médicales thérapeutiques
ou sociales qui lui seront proposés lui
permettent d'avoir un réel
accompagnement et suivi dans un système
de santé bien trop souvent inégalitaire
voire inaccessible ce car ce parcours
par nous permet aussi de désaxer le
patient de ce choix en lui offrant
d'autres solutions et alternatives une
procédure de contrôle et de traçabilité
et déployée durant tout le parcours par
ailleurs cette approche s'accompagne
d'une clause de conscience pour les
professionnels de la santé
dans le cas d'une perte ou d'une absence
de discernement la personne sera soumise
à une procédure collégiale
plurisciplinaire d'exception spécifique
et initié par le biais des directives
anticipées de la personne de confiance
ou d'une demande des proches l'ouverture
de l'euthanasie pourra alors être
envisagée
dans le cas d'un désaccord entre un
mineur personne en curatelle ou tutelle
et les parents un juge approprié statut
comprenez que c'est l'approche d'une
ouverture d'elle active à mourir la
moins discriminante à nos yeux en effet
nous permettons ainsi d'assurer une
égalité d'accès à l'aide activement
mourir sans considération médicale
sociale financière ou territoriale
chaque personne peut demander une aide
active à mourir nous replaçons le
souffrant au cœur des considérations
sociales en faisant ainsi vivre
pleinement le principe de solidarité ce
que nous craignons c'est un système qui
abandonne les personnes à mi-chemin que
certains aient le droit de ne plus
souffrir mais que d'autres soient
confrontés à cela sans aucune porte de
sortie il y a déjà des oubliés dans le
système actuel nous le souhaitons pas
qu'il y en ait davantage dans
l'ouverture de ce nouveau droit
le fait que ce choix soit possible
permet d'avoir une solution sans devoir
forcément aller jusqu'au bout du
processus ce n'est pas parce que l'on
propose que l'on impose cependant cette
ouverture ne doit pas empêcher
d'augmenter les moyens globaux alloués
au système de santé notamment pour les
soins palliatifs la viabilité de cette
approche est évidemment conditionnée à
l'occasion d'un budget suffisant pour
son application pleine et entière ce
droit universel garantit une liberté à
tous sans entraîner la moindre
obligation ce droit universel n'entame
pas le contrat social mais donne
simplement un choix complémentaire aux
personnes en souffrance dans un souci de
fraternité ce droit universel permet de
répondre à toutes les situations
rencontrées dans un esprit d'égalité
charmant de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat merci de votre
attention
mesdames messieurs bonjour donc je
représente les citoyens de la convention
qui se sont positionnés contre
l'évolution de la loi et l'ouverture à
l'aide active à mourir
[Musique]
l'ouverture complète et à l'euthanasie
et au succès d'assister donc les
chiffres sont à relativiser à expliquer
les citoyens qui se sont positionnés
contre l'ont fait pour des motifs très
divers
d'une part parce que le modèle de
civilisation
qui consistait jusque là soigner coûte
que coûte à prendre soin du patient du
malade de la personne en souffrance
risque de changer pour un modèle vers
lequel on irait vers une médecine
libérale d'un libéralisme d'opinion
finalement chacun pourrait demander à la
carte ce qui l'arrangerait et ça nous
paraît inquiétant
par ailleurs
nous n'avons pas été convaincus par la
mise en place et l'explication des
garde-fous des commissions d'enquête qui
sont censées encadrer les processus de
tanasie ou de suicide assisté
et enfin nous nous avons considéré et je
pense à raison que le centre des débats
n'était pas sur le tanazisme ou le
suicide assisté mais sur la question de
l'hôpital de sa gestion des soins
palliatifs et de l'accompagnement des
patients il y a beaucoup pas faire dans
ce domaine et les améliorations que nous
pourrions apporter à l'hôpital à sa
gestion aux soins sont un préalable à
tout autre discussion à mon avis le
comité de gouvernance qui a
pris fin qui a été en charge de
l'organisation des travaux était composé
de 14 personnes 6 membres du CESU 8
personnalités extérieures Simon du CESU
je vous expliquerai après comment ils
ont été choisis 8 personnalités
extérieures dont le président du Comité
consultatif national d'éthique
Jean-François delfresci dont François
Stas un conseiller d'État à la retraite
membre du CCNE aussi dont la directrice
du Centre national des soins palliatifs
et de la fin de vie
Cynthia Fleury spécialise des questions
d'éthique de chercheuses en charge des
questions de participation citoyenne
pour la méthode justement donc Hélène
landemort et Sandrine Ruy et deux
anciens citoyens de la convention climat
pour justement aider les décisions en
tant que ancien citoyen qui avait vécu
une expérience de participation
démocratique de ce type parmi les
critères qui ont conditionné le choix de
la présidence de ce comité de
gouvernance il y a justement le fait de
n'avoir jamais pris position sur le
sujet de la fin de vie publiquement ni
en tant que personne ni en tant que
représentant d'une organisation et c'est
important parce que le président du CESU
par exemple aurait pu présider le comité
de gouvernance mais lui justement dans
d'autres fonctions passées il avait pris
position et par souci de ne pas
contester le la légis enfin pas la
légitimité mais le l'exemplarité du
travail il a préféré se déporter et donc
moi je n'ai jamais jamais absolument
jamais pris position sur le sujet et le
CESU en 2018 quand il s'est quand il a
il a voter son avis c'était dans le
cadre d'une autre mandature avec
d'autres conseillers pour ce qui est du
fait d'avoir rendu un autre avis la
récemment vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que une loi a réformé le CESU la loi du
mois de janvier 2021 qui dit que donc le
CESU est désormais en plus d'être la
chambre de la société civile organisée
le carrefour de la participation des
publics et donc la chambre qui va être
chargée d'organiser les dispositifs
notamment de participation citoyennes
comme ça a été le cas pour cette
convention fin de vie mais ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel dit c'est que
ces travaux doivent être aussi attachés
à des travaux du CESU et donc du coup le
la décision collective qui a été prise
ça a été de dire voilà il y a un débat
national sur la fin de vie qui a été
ouvert comme je le disais par la vie du
comité d'éthique en septembre 2022 ce
débat national il a plusieurs
contributeurs
le comité d'éthique les sages les
soignants qui travaillent aussi enfin
vous avez entendu Agnès sûrement le
Baudot hier qui vous a aussi expliqué
comment elle elle avait travaillé donc
les soignants les associations etc il y
a eu plusieurs contributions il y a une
contribution centrale qui est celle de
la convention citoyenne puisque c'est la
contribution citoyenne mais il y a aussi
la contribution de la société civile
organisée qui s'est manifesté via la vie
du CESU dans le cadre de ce débat
national large qui a été rouvert au mois
de septembre donc voilà comment ça s'est
organisé pour vous répondre sur la
partie plus méthodologique et puis
ensuite sur le reste bon sur le fond je
laisserai je vous laisserai répondre
bien sûr mais peut-être juste un point
madame sur l'histoire des progressistes
et des conservateurs alors je sais pas
si c'est écrit comme ça dans un dans le
document mais voilà moi il me semble pas
qu'il y a aucun moment ce mot était
employé au contraire parce que de notre
part en tout
ah d'accord ok pardon d'accord alors
j'insiste là-dessus parce que nous notre
souci justement a été vraiment à chaque
fois de dire encore une fois il s'agit
pas de dire que certains ont tort et que
d'autres ont raison c'est vraiment pas
le sujet sur la fin de vie franchement
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un vienne
donner une leçon à quelqu'un d'autre en
lui expliquant que voilà l'un c'est
mieux que l'autre je crois que c'est pas
c'est pas ça le ça n'a jamais été pensé
ni organiser comme ça et au contraire
tout le travail a été organisé de sorte
à ce que tous les points de vue puissent
être entendus enfin vous avez entendu ce
matin trois positions différentes qui
n'ont trois pour le coup bah il y a une
différence significative entre une aide
une
aide active à mourir avec des conditions
très claires et et des conditions voilà
enfin je pense que c'est vraiment une
différence assez notable donc vous avez
trois points de vie différents qui ont
été posés qui sont représentatifs de ce
que certains membres de la Convention
ont porté et dans le livrable vous avez
tous ces points de vue qui sont posés
avec un niveau de nuances qui va quand
même très très long je crois pour une
production de ce type voilà pour le la
méthode
plume qui a tenu la plume certaines
questions de Michel meunier
c'est ça
alors le il y a une première version en
fait il y a eu des productions qui ont
été faites au fil de l'eau tous les
weekends quasiment hormis les deux
premiers week-end qui étaient des
séquences plus d'audition mais tous les
week-ends
parce que oui pardon c'est vrai qu'on
vous a pas dit ça il y a un groupe de
184 citoyens c'est un grand groupe mais
après les travaux ils ont surtout eu
lieu en plus petit groupe vous vous en
doutez produire à 184 c'est quand même
compliqué donc il y avait des groupes de
10 puis des groupes de 30 qui ont été
amenés à débattre produire des des
réponses des questions etc enfin c'est
ça c'est fait en plusieurs étapes et
donc le collectif d'animation Les les
organes enfin celles-ci qui était en
charge de l'animation des travaux donc
pas le comité de gouvernance en 6
là-dessus on rédigé un document
martyr voilà qui a ensuite été repris
par les citoyens et donc à un moment on
est allé vraiment le plus loin possible
dans le le la production citoyenne
puisqu'on a découpé le document en je
sais plus combien de part puis après
vous il y avait entre 7 et 10 citoyens
qui étaient en charge de chacune des
parties donc la rédaction et puis je
sais pas si vous êtes déjà allé au CESU
mais il y a une très grande salle qui
c'est qu'on appelle la salle hip hostile
aux ses œufs là avec les grandes
colonnes je décris pour celles et ceux
qui nous regardent mais voilà une très
grande salle et dans cette grande salle
tous les textes ont été affichés et il y
a eu un grand moment de déambulation
lors des deux derniers weekends pour que
les citoyens puissent venir modifier le
texte et à chaque fois chaque partie
était
pilotée on va dire par des rapporteurs
citoyens qui avaient été désignés par le
groupe et qui était chargé justement de
récupérer les suggestions des uns et des
autres de sorte à ce qu'à la fin il y a
quelque chose qui soit le plus
collectif et contributif possible en
sachant que voilà ça c'est un document
qui fait combien de pages je sais plus
170 pages donc c'est pas 184 personnes
qui ont écrit en se tenant la main les
194 pages évidemment vous vous en doutez
mais en tout cas tout a été revu enfin
tout a été produit revu par les citoyens
non c'est citoyens
alors qui veut répondre à d'autres
questions qui ont été posées madame
Audibert alors je vais répondre sur la
question de l'influence des pays
limitrophes et les différents exemples
européens qui pourraient nous inspirer
également effectivement nous avons
auditionner différents représentants le
il y a eu la Belgique ou le tanasie
dépénalisé il y a la Suisse également on
a entendu le Québec et l'Orégon donc ça
nous a permis un petit peu de prendre
connaissance de ce qui se passait dans
les différents pays qui soit limitrophes
ou plus éloignées et
voilà ce qu'on s'est dit c'est que nous
nous copierons pas un modèle et qu'on
ferait par contre notre propre modèle
français voilà on regarde on observe ce
qui se passe dans les différents pays
mais nous déciderons parce que nous
sommes différents voilà
bien monsieur de Bernard ensuite madame
Bériot et monsieur
je vais reprendre la phrase donc j'ai lu
tout à l'heure par ailleurs dans le cas
d'une perte ou d'une absence de
discernement l'ouverture de l'euthanasie
pourra être envisagée elle sera alors
soumise à une procédure collégiale
spécifique et initié par le biais des
directives anticipées de la personne de
confiance ou d'une demande des proches
dans le cas où une directive anticipée
n'a pas été rédigé en effet nous nous
retrouvons dans une situation où vous
pouvez avoir une personne en mort
cérébrale une personne avec un
discernement qui s'en va avec une
maladie dégénérative par exemple et nous
sommes confrontés à quelque chose de
très complexe on est d'accord donc on a
beaucoup penché là dessus et les
universels comme les conditionnés nous
retrouvons quand même bien sur ce
point-là en fait
si il y a pas de dire direction de cité
pardon mais une personne de confiance
comme dans le cadre actuel la personne
de confiance on lui fait confiance donc
on lui donne en amont l'idée de notre
fin de vie c'est à dire si un jour je
j'ai un accident de voiture que je me
retrouve à mort cérébrale je ne veux pas
continuer à vivre si quelqu'un qui a par
exemple Alzheimer qui dit le jour où je
ne reconnais plus mes enfants je veux
partir il faut prendre tout cela en
considération je suis désolé je le mets
en avant ça c'est la personne le sujet
le patient qui décide
par la suite je tiens à vous préciser
que cela est toujours soumis à un
collège d'exception spécifique qui est
initié par ces directives anticipées si
elles ne sont pas là par la personne de
confiance ou par les proches nous
pouvons mettre en avant que nous nous
plaçons si face à la législation
actuelle où il ne doit pas y avoir
d'acharnement thérapeutique premièrement
donc quelqu'un mort cérébral qu'on
continue à faire vivre au final il y a
cet acharnement là donc nous nous
plaçons aussi face à cette législation
et tout cela en fait ce se place sous la
confiance qu'on a amené en d'autres
personnes en revanche effectivement
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de proche qui n'a
pas de personne de confiance pas de
directive anticipée nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation très complexe et là
c'est aussi à la justice de tranchée
pour la partie sans discernement pour la
partie
justement de personnes en mort céréales
là il faut aussi faire confiance à la
justice il faut faire confiance à des
médecins il faut faire confiance à des
psychiatres accompagner la famille
auditionner tout le monde et c'est comme
ça qu'on pourra trouver des solutions
assez problèmes rencontrées mais comme
on en a déjà trouvé dans des cas comme
Vincent Lambert et ça nous sommes déjà
retrouvés confrontés à cela
merci madame la Présidente je rajoute
qu'on a aussi entendu les Pays-Bas par
rapport à la liste des personnes et que
c'est sûr que ce qui se passe autour de
la France impact évidemment la France et
qui me semble que là on en est à la
deuxième convention citoyenne sur ce
sujet quand même pas dans les mêmes
formats mais qui avait conclu à la même
chose et que on a pas mal de sondages
encore une fois des citoyens qui disent
que il faut faire évoluer cette
situation qui est pose problème pour un
certain nombre de personnes sur
l'hypocrisie alors le lien avec la loi
que l'AS Leonetti c'est sûr qu'il y a
24% des citoyens qui connaissent pas la
loi ça on est bien d'accord il y a des
médecins on l'a vu on a vu aussi qu'il y
avait plein de gens qui ne savaient pas
ce qui était des directives anticipées
ce qui ne savait pas ce que ce qui était
la personne de confiance qui pense que
quand on va à l'hôpital et qu'on donne
le nom de quelqu'un c'est sa personne de
confiance on sait bien que c'est pas ça
mais en fait je crois que c'est pas
vraiment le problème comment je passais
je vais penser aux jeux mais mes
collègues conditionnés moi-même nous
parlons de enfin du fait qu'il y a des
euthanasies et qui a une hypocrisie
c'est que de fait contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu entendre lors de l'audition des
fédérations des sociétés savantes que
vous avez reçues nous en 4 mois on a
entendu pas mal de gens qui nous ont dit
d'autres témoignages donc vraiment qui
disait que il y avait des euthanasies
qui ne portent pas ce nom là donc je
pense qu'on peut faire comme si ça
n'était pas le cas mais de fait il y a
en France des euthanasies et même la loi
aujourd'hui que la esleonetti ne permet
pas pour un certain nombre de raisons de
résoudre tous ces problèmes donc on nous
sommes peut-être que nous ne l'avons pas
dit assez clairement évidemment tous au
sein de la convention pour que il y ait
un gros travail de communication pour
que le Conseil national des soins
palliatifs et fin de vie prennent
vraiment encore plus de l'ampleur et
soit vraiment l'opérateur de cela pour
que la loi soit connue mais de fait
aujourd'hui
d'accord l'ordre des médecins ok
sur mort solidaire est-ce que
l'euthanasie est un soin alors oui c'est
terrible je sais bien je pense je pense
que hélas oui aujourd'hui la médecine
permet de vivre longtemps aujourd'hui je
pense que personne ici ne peut dire
qu'il mourra de mort naturelle parce que
nous avons tous eu des opérations nous
avons tous eu des médicaments où nous en
avons aujourd'hui la mort naturelle dans
nos sociétés ça n'existe plus en
revanche ce qui existe c'est des sites
en tout cas pas beaucoup et en revanche
ce qui existe c'est des situations ou
des personnes vont avoir des
polypathologies vont être maintenues
parce qu'on a une médecine absolument
fabuleuse avec des médecins hyper
compétents qui permettent vraiment de
nous permettre d'avancer beaucoup plus
loin mais ça nous semble vraiment
important de permettre à des personnes
qui seraient dans des situations de
souffrance inapaisables parce que ça
existe que ces personnes puissent
accéder à un moyen d'aide actif à
Montréal
le ministre de la Santé a répondu non
parce qu'on lui a posé ce que le
l'euthanasie est-elle un soin pour
Monsieur Braun répond ce qu'il veut nous
conventions citoyenne répondons
absolument voilà mais il est dans son
rôle c'est ce que nous en dire les
médecins qui pratiquent le tanaser en
Belgique pour eux en effet c'était le
soin jusqu'au bout après on peut être
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord très bien
monsieur
Jovanovic
je vais répondre à plusieurs questions
dans l'ordre le modèle étranger le
modèle suisse moi il se trouve que
j'habite en Haute-Savoie et j'ai pu
interroger un médecin des soins
palliatifs de ma région qui auparavant
travaillant en Suisse et retourner
travailler en France dans des soins
palliatifs après son expérience Suisse
et avec un préjudice financier que vous
imaginez mais elle ne regrette pas une
seconde son choix sa décision de
travailler avec des patients en fin de
vie et de faire ce travail
d'accompagnement elle m'a même dit les
larmes aux yeux que c'était la chose la
plus enrichissante et la plus incroyable
qu'elle a eu de sa carrière et donc
la fin de vie peut être difficile les
l'idée de de soit anticiper de personnes
de confiance qu'on aurait donné à un
tenter ou notre discernement aurait été
telle le discernement change et puis
vous savez que
il peut être manipulé il peut être il
peut être influencé la notion de
discernement me paraît un mauvais
critère pour décider du destin
d'un être humain
non c'est un choix de société un choix
de vie qui doit s'imposer à la société
et non pas le discernement privé
ça c'était pour le modèle suisse qui est
pas qui a effrayé je dois dire plus qui
est frais beaucoup de citoyens de la
Convention et qui est justement pour ça
ce sont positionnés contre
parce que c'est c'est le modèle suisse
c'est un peu une cérémonie une mise en
spectacle assez morbide qui fait peur
c'est pas
ensuite ça c'est pour le suicide pardon
pas pour l'euthanasie
[Musique]
donc les chiffres les chiffres
importants de citoyen qui voulait que la
loi évolue parmi ceux-ci il y a des gens
qui ne veulent pas ni d'euthanasie ni de
suicide assisté
donc effectivement on aurait on aurait
eu intérêt lors de la convention à
prendre plus de temps à analyser la
question de Madame le Premier ministre
il est dommage qu'on ne l'ai pas fait et
on a rapidement été orienté sur la
question euthanasie suicide assisté et
je crois que c'est par moult combat
qu'on est revenu sur la question des
soins palliatifs hier effectivement on a
eu aussi l'audition de la ministre Agnès
Firmin le Bodo et elle elle a parlé de
de trois de trois volets extrêmement
importants qui tenaient à cœur au
gouvernement le développement des soins
palliatifs je vais vite l'ouverture d'un
nouveau droit donc l'aide active à
mourir et la protection des personnes et
du droit des personnes alors
effectivement
je pense que c'est une bonne façon de de
prendre cette question et vous l'avez
vous l'avez développé moi il me semble
qu'il faut pas il faut vraiment pas
lâcher vous n'avez pas lâché
la question des soins palliatifs a
vraiment développé parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une inégalité entre les
départements entre les territoires donc
entre les personnes et je crois qu'il
l'une d'entre vous l'a dit on peut pas
non plus décorer les à l'état actuel de
notre système de santé et des hôpitaux
qui avec la meilleure volonté du monde
manque de personnel donc de moyens
financiers humains donc tout ça c'est
effectivement à mettre en lien je pense
aussi que c'est important de dire que
c'est une réflexion qui n'est pas qui
doit être aussi une réflexion de pas
privé mais de la société tout entière et
et moi ce qui me disons me tient à cœur
dans la façon de dire qu'il faut
revisiter la loi
avec toute tous les garde-fous parce
qu'il peut y avoir des dérives et on le
sait pertinemment c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas il y a une
grande inégalité parce que les gens
qu'on les moyens financiers de le faire
qui ont une famille qui peut les
accompagner et bien ont accès à
l'euthanasie ou à l'aide active à mourir
enfin le suicide assisté pardon le
suicide assisté et ça je trouve que on
ne peut pas faire comme si ça n'existait
pas on peut continuer à dire mais non
parce qu'il va y avoir des dérives etc
c'est vrai que mais vous l'avez dit
toute loi peut-être des voyelles il y a
jamais quelque chose de de parfait mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui de ces
inégalités inégalités qui pour moi est
une inégalité sociale et je trouve que
on doit être interpellé par le sujet et
faire en sorte justement de penser à
tout le monde tout le monde doit être
égal et moi c'est la grosse question qui
me tient à cœur
merci madame la Présidente merci à tous
pour de la convention citoyenne pour
l'explication de de vos travaux donc la
convention citoyenne a fait connaître
effectivement les soins palliatifs il y
en a qui connaissaient pas et notamment
dans certains départements il y a des
lits qui sont
qui sont initiés soins palliatifs et
d'autres alors qu'il y a pas d'unité de
soins palliatifs mais ça fonctionne
quand même très bien
je voudrais rappeler que
si vous voulez
en Hollande vous n'avez pas cité la
Hollande je vais la cité 90% de
personnes atteintes de maladies très
graves avec pronostic de décès à brève
échéance
et bien il y en avait 90% en 2002 qui
avait subi une euthanasie donc là ça
faisait 1800 et en 2018 et il y en a
7000 avec seulement 60% qui était en fin
de vie et
donc il est indiqué que si les soins
palliatifs avaient été existé en
Hollande et bien
ignorer pas eu de d'aide à mourir et
donc je voulais donc vous demander dans
ma première question si vous voulez
comment
et bien quelle barrière supplémentaire
par rapport à ce pays allez vous mettre
en œuvre pour que cette dérive ne se
produise pas en France deuxièmement la
loi léonétique laisse c'est une sédation
profonde et continue présente dans nos
départements aldonnance tiers
satisfaction par contre effectivement
vous l'avez dit et je pense qu'il faut
accompagnement sûrement améliorer par
davantage de personnels le renforcer oui
les soins palliatifs pour tous tout à
fait oui je voudrais rappeler que
lorsque les personnes sont malades et
bien elles peuvent changer ou si elles
deviennent des menthes elles peuvent
changer complètement par rapport au
directives anticipées disons l'immense
majorité des malades lorsque ça se
dégrade et bien elles veulent être
soignées et donc je voudrais rappeler
aussi que 80% du personnel des soins
palliatifs ne souhaitent pas le suicide
assister tout comme plus de 80% des
personnes en EHPAD est-ce que vous allez
tenir compte donc de des avis de ce
personnel qui sont qui sont confrontés
tous les jours aux fin de vie et vous
avez dit aussi que
en fin de vie
le suicide assisté ou l'euthanasie
c'était donc
[Musique]
pourquoi pas dans un premier temps
développer des soins palliatifs
préalablement à toute décision
merci madame la Présidente moi d'abord
je voulais vous remercier pour pour
l'intelligence du travail que vous avez
produit et
j'allais dire d'abord parce que
jusqu'ici jusqu'à votre travail la
parole des citoyens c'était les sondages
qu'on nous débiter un après l'autre et
qui disait 90% des gens sont pour
l'euthanasie 85%, 92% des gens qui sont
pas euthanasie et là vous avez vous êtes
entré dans la complexité de la question
et on voit qu'en entrant dans la
complexité la question d'abord vous avez
bien différencié le système l'euthanasie
dans l'aide activaway etc et là en fait
moi plutôt que les chiffres donc j'ai
pas grand chose à faire j'ai vu vos
votes successifs une qui traduisent en
fait la complexité de la question et je
suis convaincu qu'en regard des
intitulés des votes que en fonction
d'ailleurs des conditionnalités des
contextes que vous posez il y a des
votes qui bougeraient si les conditions
n'était pas rempli si si etc dans un
sens ou dans l'autre peut-être donc moi
je trouve que c'est extrêmement sain que
yus ce travail à collectif citoyen que
vous ayez mené et qui vient nous
rapporter à nous parlementaires qui
devronter
l'évolution éventuelle de la loi le
fruit de votre travail et donc je vais
pas du tout entrer dans le débat sur le
fond c'est parce que je souhaite faire
aujourd'hui mais moi j'ai une question à
vous poser c'est la phase parlementaire
qui s'ouvre elle va être très longue
puisque on sera pas vous savez
d'habitude le gouvernement impose
toujours la procédure accélérée c'est à
dire faut bâcler les textes et discuter
très rapidement et là pour une fois pour
une fois c'est très rare il va respecter
la procédure normale ça veut dire qu'on
est parti allez au minimum pour un an et
plutôt 18 mois de procédure
parlementaires c'est 2024 pas avant en
tout cas l'aboutissement à la potion
est-ce que vous estimez que votre rôle
il est terminé complètement la saisie
est terminée vous avez rendu votre avis
ou est-ce que vous estimez que au cours
de cette procédure parlementaire vous
pouvez avoir encore un rôle
d'interaction avec nous avec les députés
avec les sénateurs pour voilà échanger
pour je le dis parce que les membres de
la Convention citoyenne sur le climat on
a vu qu'il y avait une sorte de
frustration alors après on a vu des
appels de de collective de membres
certains sont présentés aux élections
d'ailleurs c'est une autre question mais
on a vu que des groupes de membres de la
Convention citoyenne on continuait à
produire en fait derrière voilà mais je
trouve que c'est imparfait je trouve que
la richesse de votre processus c'est
d'avoir tenu tout le monde quel que soit
les avis dans le processus jusqu'à terme
et ça c'est aussi un beau succès voilà
comment vous voyez la suite
alors Raymond de penser toutes les
questions vous notez si vous avez des
vraiment de penser mon rouge oui alors
merci pour ce travail parce que
effectivement moi je trouve que
parce que si on devait qualifier le
rapport c'est vraiment qu'il n'est pas
maniqué
vouloir changer la loi c'est pas
forcément progressiste qui a souvent on
change la
loi on a des exemples récents et c'est
pas progressif c'est tout à fait
agressif et donc
je veux dire les progressistes c'est pas
ceux qui veulent changer la loi enfin
forcément c'est en toute état de cause
moi j'ai lu le rapport et je l'ai trouvé
tout à fait représentatif de ce qu'adieu
être votre débat quant à la question
posée la question posée elle a été
ouverte par le comité éthique enfin je
veux dire c'est un petit peu eux qui ont
ouvert la question et
ils ont alors c'est pas pour ça qu'ils
l'ont ouvert mais
de fait ils ont répondu à une demande
sociétale très forte d'ouvrir la
question enfin bon alors moi ce que par
rapport je veux pas on n'est pas là pour
donner notre comment est-ce que on se
met dans les quatre catégories moi j'en
avais merci à tous mettons trois
qu'importe
moi j'aimerais savoir si vous avez
évalué enfin bon comme ça dans vos
discussions formelles ou informelles le
bouger de vous positions parce que tout
le monde de fait c'est pas que ça soit
les chiffres que donner Bernard mais
tout le monde de fait a été c'est un
débat qui qui est là depuis longtemps a
été amené conduit à réfléchir quand même
un petit peu à ce qui serait sa position
et vous est-ce que vous avez pu échanger
là-dessus sur le bouger de vos positions
et ce si je dis ça c'est par rapport
aussi à ce que disait Bernard
c'est-à-dire que nous on va rentrer dans
un long tunnel parlementaire et comment
le travail que vous avez fait qui est en
fin de compte un débat éclairé comme
l'avait été la convention citoyenne sur
le climat et comment à partir d'un d'un
débat éclairé la position la position
qui qui en vient comment nous enfin
comment la société doit accompagner
enfin quels sont les débats encore à
poursuivre à mener et de qualité et pas
de façon manichéenne pour que les
Français fassent alors pas en façon
accélérée par le temps accélérer que ça
parce qu'ils ont un an pour le faire
mais le même chemin le même cheminement
que vous avez fait avec ce qui est le
cœur de ma question à savoir le bouger
des positions voilà
je voulais dire aussi que bon enfin
c'est une parenthèse j'ai dit que
j'allais pas donner mais le groupe
parlementaire dont je faisais partie qui
est allé en Suisse pas du tout vécu que
vous avez eu et ça sera très intéressant
d'en discuter parce que vraiment la
Suisse voilà avec les soignants avec les
équipes qui le font avec les y compris
il y avait des représentants religieux
enfin il y avait rien d'effrayant dans
dans l'exemple je remercie
chacun est Madame Toury conclura
Florence Larade
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
vais poser des questions assez courtes
sur le recrutement vous avez vous avez
expliqué comment vous étiez recruté je
voudrais savoir quel est l'âge moyen je
voudrais savoir si parmi vous vous êtes
nombreux à avoir eu dans votre entourage
ou professionnellement une expérience de
fin de vie pénible ou pas et je voulais
savoir comment comment sont compensés
les journées que vous passez est-ce que
vous êtes indemnisé
voilà je sais très simplement ce que je
voulais demander
sont très pratiques aux pratiques
Véronique Guillotin et Martin lévrier
rouge vous avez évoqué plusieurs moments
des lignes rouges je vais rajouter
derrière les conditions non remplies et
vous l'avez évoqué aussi alors dans les
lignes rouges je les ai pas entendues
donc est-ce qu'il y a quelques lignes
rouges que vous avez mis comme ne
pouvant pas du coup est-ce que la loi ne
pourrait pas évoluer si c'est lignes
rouges n'étaient pas remplies et dans
les lignes rouges ou en tout cas les
conditions de remplir vous avez évoqué
les budgets les moyens les kittés
territoriales etc tout ce que l'on ne
sait pas faire aujourd'hui en matière de
santé simple et de soins palliatifs
comment pensez-vous évaluer ça avant de
vous prononcer puisque vous avez
considéré que c'était pas possible de
mettre en place un système qui était
plus inégalitaire que ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui et un deuxième sujet c'est
l'encadrement médical si j'ai bien
compris donc est-ce que l'encadrement
médical vous avez considéré qu'il était
nécessaire que ce soit fait dans un
encadrement médical que la mort active
soit mise dans un encadrement médical le
système de l'Oregon pas à proprement
parler d'un encadrement médical strict
puisque les gens sont à la maison donc
est-ce que c'est pour vous un rejet a
priori donc de ce système de type Oregon
et puis je rentrerai pas non plus dans
dans le débat il y a plein de choses où
je peux être d'accord d'autres non mais
c'est pas je crois que c'est pas le
sujet en tout cas je pense que ça
éclaire sur effectivement globalement
les divers questions que l'on se pose
tous et chacun dans notre parlementaire
individuel donc voilà je pense que le
débat continuera à dérouler mais c'est
les deux questions que j'aurais voulu
poser
parce que j'avais elle était inscrite et
je suis désolé Martin mais Martin
lévrier conclura conclura les questions
merci Madame ma présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs pour vos pour vos
témoignages moi je voudrais plus vous
poser des questions sur la forme que sur
le fond on disait que pour le fond on
aura sûrement beaucoup d'auditions
beaucoup de discussions et des temps de
réflexion pour se positionner je voulais
savoir ce que vous retenez de cette
expérience de toutes ces heures que vous
avez passé ensemble à réfléchir à
discuter comment est-ce que vous avez
géré les désaccords et ce que vous savez
dans quelle proportion les avis des
membres de la Convention ont pu évoluer
au cours des travaux réalisés et puis
plus spécifiquement à madame Claire
Toury le bilan que vous tirez de ces
quatre mois et surtout est-ce que vous
avez identifié des pistes d'amélioration
en vue des potentiels prochaine
conventions sur d'autres sujets et
est-ce que vous pensez que tous les
sujets peuvent faire l'objet de telles
conventions merci
merci madame la Présidente très
rapidement un député européen qui est de
ma ville mais pas de maline politique
a battu en brèche vos auditions en
disant qu'elles étaient parfaitement
orientées et que il n'y avait pas eu
donc de vrais débats que tout était
orienté que moi j'aimerais bien savoir
quoi vous m'expliquez un peu comment ont
été choisis justement pour parce qu'il y
a pas eu de contradiction sur ce sujet
je trouve que c'est toujours embêtant un
peu nous expliquer comment vous avez pas
entendu répète rappelez-moi parce que
j'ai été un peu étonné de ça donc un peu
expliqué comment était choisis les
personnes que vous avez auditionnées une
autre question si la loi Clayes Leonetti
avait été parfaitement appliquée est-ce
que vous pensez que votre approche de la
question de la première ministre aurait
été la même ou pas
une autre question si le Parlement
modifie tout ou grande partie de vos
préconisations comment réagirez-vous et
puis tout dernière question beaucoup
plus personnelle et un peu pour sourire
en fait ce que vous avez fait vous avez
découvert ce que nous faisons 80% du
temps est-ce que ça vous a donné envie
de passer en politique ou pas du tout
merci
merci madame la Présidente de redonner
la parole juste je voulais réagir à
votre affirmation madame Berriot si vous
le permettez tout à l'heure quand vous
avez dit que la main naturelle n'existe
pas
comment
qualifiez-vous la mort de quelqu'un qui
décède brutalement d'un infarctus passif
et que pensez-vous de l'affirmation de
nos voisins belges qui disent que
quelqu'un qui meurt par l'euthanasie a
une mort naturelle
en clair quel est votre définition de la
demande naturelle s'il vous plaît pour
terminer à l'un Dufour et là on va
arrêter ensuite Alain Dufour
merci
mesdames merci Monsieur pour ce rapport
pour juste rapidement une question une
observation
aujourd'hui c'est la convention
citoyenne Conseil national de la
refondation c'est la méthode Macron tout
le monde le sait alors ma première
question et le Parlement dans tout ça et
sur le sur le fond comment garantir
surtout la réelle application des soins
palliatifs dans les EHPAD et je pense
que à mon niveau je crois que la c'est
la loi Leonetti me convient parfaitement
et c'est l'été appliqué dans son
ensemble résoudrait beaucoup de
problèmes et on n'aurait pas à se poser
ces questions aujourd'hui
on commence allez monsieur je vanovic
vous allez démarrer une petite
conclusion
de même
beaucoup de questions
concernant le elle est dans l'ordre
concernant notre présentation ici à nous
tous vous avez remarqué on est quatre
participants il y a un contre il y a 2
pour un troisième je sais pas
et moi j'estime que alors sans étiquette
mais avec opinion il faudra expliquer
par ailleurs moi j'estime que nous-mêmes
les contre on a galéré pour se retrouver
ici on est arrivé et puis finalement je
pense aussi que je représente beaucoup
de courants d'opinion on a beaucoup de
subtilités on aurait pu être 4 entre des
conservateurs qui peut-être étaient
contre la loi pour des questions de
principes et des gens qui ont évolué et
qui ont été à l'écoute des médecins qui
pour finalement se positionner contre
l'évolution de la loi alors qu'a priori
ils auraient été plutôt on va dire entre
guillemets progressiste donc moi oui je
suis tout seul mais ça me va très bien
et j'ai la consolation de ma camarade
par ailleurs par ailleurs alors
l'évolution vous avez parlé de
l'évolution des groupes nous étions un
groupe assez peu nombreux au départ je
pense les contre et nous n'avons cessé
de croître on est un groupe on est les
contre sont été 39% certainement de
citoyens ce qui est pas négligeable plus
nombreux je pense que certains de mes
camarades
par ailleurs l'évolution elle a été le
résultat de l'écoute des médecins pour
la plupart de des contre donc le fait
d'avoir écouté les médecins de l'avoir
entendu leurs arguments et leur les
médecins n'ont pas donné de position
quand ils nous parlait mais ça a
convaincu beaucoup de citoyens de
s'attacher aux soins palliatifs avant
d'envisager quoi que ce soit d'autre
donc moi je dirais puisque vous ferez la
même chose que nous et ce sera pareil à
l'Assemblée nationale être à l'écoute
des médecins c'est toujours une bonne
chose
ensuite
merci Monsieur
les lignes rouges et les conditions pour
ce qui est des lignes rouges on avait
clairement je pense le notre convention
nationale à rejeter l'idée d'ouvrir les
nouveaux droits aux mineurs
alors ça ça a été vraiment une ligne
rouge assez
clairement et très majoritaire
ce qui est des conditions prérequises à
l'ouverture de nouveaux droits il aurait
effectivement l'application pleine et
entière de la loi classique donc de
grâce avant d'envisager quoi que ce soit
jouer au jeu de la loi classe Leonetti
et appliquons là sur tout le territoire
je termine il reste encore quelques
questions intéressantes
elles étaient toutes intéressantes bien
sûr ce que nous retenons de cette
expérience notre expérience je remercie
claire Touri le 16e les organisateurs je
pense je parle en mon nom mais aussi au
nom de beaucoup de citoyens que j'ai
rencontrés ça nous a fait un peu plus
aimer la France ça nous a fait un peu
plus aimer notre système démocratique ça
nous a fait un peu plus aimer le fait de
s'impliquer dans la société et je
voudrais
sincèrement très chaleureusement et
presque l'alarme à l'oeil remercier le
16e et l'initiative qui nous a réuni
voilà
sur la question plus délicate de
l'orientation des débats
vous savez
le problème vient de la formulation des
questions et souvent de l'ordre
d'exposition nous n'avons jamais eu on
nous on a essayé de faire voter pour
savoir combien de personnes étaient
contre le Tanzi ce vote ne nous a pas
été ouvert
non
et puis
il est vrai que la formulation des
questions nous n'avions pas la main
dessus je le regrette et donc je pense
que c'est une chose constructive
constructive pardon pour améliorer le
modèle de démocratie participative il y
aurait beaucoup pas dire que ce soit le
groupe des comptes qui s'est senti
frustré très souvent que le groupe des
cours qui aurait voulu aussi
participer au niveau de la formulation
des questions et de l'ordre des votes
alors il y a toute une réflexion à faire
nous l'avons commencé nous voir les ex
on s'appelle déjà les ex conventionnels
on a commencé cette réflexion elle est
intéressante j'espère qu'elle sera utile
à de futurs conventions et à tous ceux
qui représentent le peuple français
voilà merci merci à tous
je fais vite alors je voulais répondre
quand même quelques questions notamment
dans le désordre monsieur Chassin je
crois qui posait différentes questions
et notamment vous évoquez le chiffre de
80% des soignants
d'où sort ce chiffre qui quel est le
sondage qu'il n'est soin palliatifs vous
vous basez sur l'enquête de la safap ok
d'accord
qui est une enquête ou en fait il y a eu
135 soignants finalement qui ont dit
qu'il ne voulait pas
travailler là-dessus qui ne voulait pas
si la loi était modifiée continuer à
travailler dans les soins palliatifs je
vous raconte sur une anecdote parce
qu'elle me semble bien illustré le truc
en fait on parle beaucoup des médecins
mais je pense que c'est bien de parler
des médecins et des soignants j'ai été
invité à la FEA
j'ai été invitée à la Fiat qui est donc
une Fédération Hospitalière privée il y
avait un sondage où on voyait qu'il y
avait une grande dichotomie entre la
position des médecins et la position des
des soignants et où en fait tout le
personnel qui était au chevet du patient
était plus proche de l'aide de
l'ouverture de l'aide active à mourir
que les médecins en tout cas c'est ce
qui était dans le sondage après on en
fait ce qu'on en veut je pense que ça
c'est important aussi de voir d'où l'on
parle à chaque fois donc 80% des
soignants je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être voir ce qu'il en est je pense
que en termes vous parliez de la dérive
nous ce qu'on propose pour éviter des
dérives c'est ce qu'on a essayé
d'expliquer avec Antonin c'est en fait
le parcours c'est à dire qu'évidemment
pour nous nous voyons pas l'ouverture de
l'aide active à mourir comme étant une
option comme on prendrait je ne sais pas
n'importe quelle option sur doctolib
c'est vraiment dans le cadre d'un
parcours avec un accompagnement médical
très sérieux d'une équipe
pluridisciplinaire voire
interdisciplinaire pour voir si vraiment
cette personne peut suivre et accéder à
cette aide active à Montréal vous disiez
aussi les personnes malades changent
mais même les personnes en fait qui sont
en bonne santé on sait bien que les
directives anticipées finalement ça ça
nous a été ça nous a été dit moult fois
les directives anticipées il faut les
refaire refaire refaire parce que quand
on est en bonne santé à un moment donné
on évolue et vous le disiez tout à fait
justement quand on a des pathologies qui
commencent à venir finalement ce qui
nous semblait insupportable
insupportable et donc on change au fil
de l'eau donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important ce que nous en dit les
équipes soignantes aussi
sait que en fait ce qu'il faut surtout
voir c'est le milieu c'est les personnes
de confiance la famille etc qui nous
permet ensuite d'avoir une une opinion
et de savoir si la personne veut
toujours veut toujours cette chose là
je pense
c'était votre question aussi madame sur
ce que ça nous a apporté moi ce que ça
m'a beaucoup apporté c'est que
finalement on voit bien que si on donne
un collectif quel qu'il soit de
l'information de la formation il est
tout à fait capable de produire un
rapport que moi j'estime de qualité vous
nous en avez remercié on vous remercie
pour ça et on pense qu'on peut vraiment
être un allié dans le Parlement
contrairement à monsieur qui n'est pas
là mais j'aurais voulu lui dire que on
s'inscrit pas du tout à la place des
parlementaires nous on pense qu'on peut
être vraiment un appui au parlementaire
et notamment parce que les conventions
citoyennes il y en a de par le monde ça
n'est pas comme il l'a dit la méthode
des conventions citoyennes il en existe
il y en a eu plus de 400 qui ont été
faites dans des pays aussi improbables
que le Pakistan le Bangladesh etc c'est
que ça doit être possible quand même de
faire ce genre de choses sur la mort
naturelle alors je précise en fait ce
que je voulais dire par là je m'appuyais
sur des propos qui sont des propos de
Martin Lombard que vous avez peut-être
accueilli ici qui est une juriste qui a
écrit un livre remarquable qui s'appelle
l'ultime demande et puis les
interventions de Véronique Fournier
souvent qui sont donc vous la connaissez
la personne qui a mis au point qui a
créé le Centre des tiques cliniques de
Cochin qui disait que finalement avec le
fait que nous avons des médicaments
depuis que nous sommes petits etc mais
en fait ça on peut plus dire maintenant
qu'on est sur des morts naturels
oui oui j'ai compris mais je vous dis
d'où ça vient on peut ne pas être
d'accord pas de problème il y a pas de
vie naturelle non plus
je peux pas vous dire sur ce truc là
oui oui mais
que la mort est naturel c'est que quand
le médecin le médecin légiste coche il
fait ça pour pas qu'il y ait eu une
enquête en assassinat homicide etc je
veux pas de faire un autre chose
cette formulation qui peut-être vous a
choqué c'était l'idée de dire que
surtout on peut pas avoir enfin on a des
une médecine encore une fois qui est
formidable en France vraiment avec qui
permet de soigner beaucoup de choses
mais au moment où cette médecine notre
système de santé extrêmement cure dans
le curatif au moment où cette médecine
ne peut plus rien pour nous je trouve
que c'est un abandon de soins auprès du
patient et donc du coup cette histoire
de nous dire tout le temps il faut
maintenant que la personne meurt
naturellement n'a pas de sens je vais le
formuler comme ça plutôt peut-être ce
sera plus précis par rapport
oui oui donc j'arrête là j'arrête là et
si je dis une dernière chose si je peux
me permettre oui là sur la mort
solidaire et solitaire en fait je pense
que nous ce qu'on a vraiment réussi à
faire dans la convention citoyenne je
prends un petit peu de hauteur pour pas
répondre comme ça c'est qu'on n'a pas
opposé les deux et que la loi classe
Léonetti qui serait appliquée à 100% ne
répond toujours pas aux problématiques
des personnes qui ne sont pas avec un
pronostic vital engagé à court terme ça
ne répond pas à ça donc nous on est on
sera avec les parlementaires pour
travailler sur les soins palliatifs et
aussi pour l'ouverture de l'aide active
à mourir merci
merci Nathalie pour répondre à la
première intervention de Madame Cohen je
crois
tout d'abord merci pour pour vos mots je
ne peux corrigendre vos propos cette
convention citoyenne c'est basé sur le
respect l'écoute de tout un chacun nous
sommes sur un sujet très sensible qui
est la fin de vie évidemment que nous
sommes tous liés à ça nous avons tous
été confrontés à une situation de fin de
vie d'un proche de dadami enfin c'est
très compliqué à gérer et forcément
l'émotion se mêle à ce mail à la
réflexion on ne peut pas le nier c'est
pourquoi nous avons été très bien
accompagnés aux ces œufs c'est pourquoi
il y avait des coachs des psy qui était
là aussi pour accompagner les citoyens
qui souffraient de de reparler de
situation de mort de proche etc donc
c'était assez compliqué il y a trois
volets importants comme vous l'avez
signifié qui ont été mis en avant par
Madame Agnès Firmin loboto le
développement des soins palliatifs
l'ouverture de l'aide active à mourir et
la protection des personnes et des
droits des personnes nous rejoignons
cela pour le ceux qui sont pro ou aides
ouverture de la taxi va mourir la ligne
rouge monsieur le lien lévrier pardon je
suis désolé les lois en fait
n'évolueront pas sans accompagnement
et une évolution
[Rires]
des budgets alloués à la santé et pour
les 100 palliatifs et pour la formation
et pour arrêter avec cette inégalité
territoriale donc par exemple les soins
palliatifs et les lois la pardon la loi
n'évolera pas la ligne rouge c'est aussi
le fait qu'il faut un parcours
d'accompagnement sans se parcours
d'accompagnement il n'y a pas des à
mourir qui devrait être ouverte en fait
parce que nous devons accompagner nous
devons protéger les personnes nous
revenons donc sur protection des
personnes des droits des personnes il y
a eu énormément de votes nous avons
énormément travaillé je tiens à appuyer
le fait que nous avons pu faire
retravailler les votes que nous avons pu
nous impliquer dans le processus
démocratique osez je vais vous donner un
exemple un jour j'étais tout à fait en
désaccord avec une méthode j'ai été le
dire j'ai été voir les animateurs les
facilitateurs nous avons tout remis en
place 5 heures de travail en plus nous
avons terminé à 23 heures ce jour-là
le CESU était à notre écoute la
transparence et la traçabilité était de
mise c'était magnifique vous aviez des
dossiers mais remplis avec tout le
processus de traçabilité et c'est là
dessus que je souhaite appuyer très
fortement
en ce qui concerne l'encadrement médical
oui nous devons
procéder à l'aide activé à mourir
encadrer encadré par des soignants
cadrés par des médecins pas de Kill pile
à la maison comme en origon nous sommes
contre cela trop de dérives nous sommes
d'accord concernant les dérives bon
toute progression sociale toute pardon
excusez-moi toute évolution sociale tout
est l'évolution de la loi en fait se
confronte aux dérives pour reprendre
l'IVG nous pourrons prendre l'abolition
de la peine de mort à chaque fois chaque
évolution de la société nous sommes
confrontés à cette crainte de la dérive
mais je suis persuadé que l'intelligence
collective l'intelligence humaine
l'intelligence sociétale
et dans les législations permettent
d'empêcher ces derniers nous n'allons
pas tomber dans une dystopie parce que
nous aurons les activa mourir
aucun des citoyens mais pour une
ouverture de l'aide active à mourir sans
condition vous pouvez penser que ce que
je représente c'est sans condition mais
ça ne l'est pas il y a des conditions il
y a un parcours d'accompagnement il y a
une épouse du passant il y a une
révocabilité de la demande c'est
toujours possible de revenir en arrière
il n'y aura pas de dérive à mes yeux
tout cela est soumis à réflexion
mais c'était la crainte d'une nouvelle
évolution la crainte d'une évolution de
dans la loi de l'autorisation de l'IVG
de l'abolition de la peine de la police
de la peine de mort que tout le monde
allait procéder à l'iviger ce n'est pas
le cas tout le monde va pas se jeter
vers le tanazi on parle bien de
personnes en souffrance nous n'allons
pas nous retrouver avec des gens qui
vont foncer tête baissée dans la mort
les gens ne veulent pas mourir en fait
personne ne veut réellement mourir et
attendez certains veulent mourir
certains veulent mourir certains sont
suicidaires et justement d'ouvrir un
parcours d'accompagnement d'ouvrir
l'écoute de faire rentrer les gens dans
ce parcours encadré par des spécialistes
encadrés par des psychiatres mais c'est
leur donner une chance c'est leur donner
une porte de sortie et quelque part une
idée que c'est possible sans forcément
vouloir le faire au Québec il y a un
grand pourcentage de personnes qui sont
allés chercher celles qu'ils qui ne
l'ont finalement pas prise
tout le même cela veut dire beaucoup de
choses je continue je ne vais pas trop
trop m'attarder excusez-moi
donc pour revenir sur l'intelligence
collective les conventions citoyennes
c'est vraiment ça que ça nous a apporté
et c'est la confiance en nous la
confiance en cette intelligence nous
pouvons faire beaucoup de choses
ensemble et remettre le citoyen au cœur
du processus c'est lui permettre d'avoir
un nouveau confiance dans les process de
démocratie dans les institutions car il
y a vous le savez une peur du citoyen
une crainte une fois forcément on voit
les contestations sociales et lui
redonner la parole lui redonner la
parole et vraiment impactant et c'est ce
que nous avons ressenti et nous
remercions le 16e pour cette pour cette
grande
découverte cette grande expérience le
fait de se rapprocher de la démocratie
pour ma part j'ai toujours été un petit
peu rebelle bah au final je me retrouve
tout à fait en lien avec ce qui s'est
passé je suis heureux d'avoir partagé la
participation à ce process je reprends
des études en transition écologique et
solidaire j'aimerais aller vers la
politique vers l'intelligence collective
pour vous répondre monsieur
et désolé pour la pour les roses sur le
nom donc voilà je voulais vraiment vous
remercier de nous avoir écouté et je
vais laisser la parole à Madame Clotilde
de dibert qui vous appuiera d'autres
points
alors je vais répondre brièvement parce
que mes amis ont déjà répondu à pas mal
de questions mais oui je complète donc
pour nous il y a véritablement l'intérêt
à développer les conventions citoyennes
pour vous aider parlementaire parce que
ça permet une réflexion finalement de la
société tout entière on se rend compte
que on a des citoyens extrêmement
engagés qui s'intéressent au sujet parce
qu'on a tous un vécu différent on a des
sensibilités différentes donc il est
important de les écouter de les entendre
de les comprendre aussi donc pour nous
ça a été extrêmement important ça nous a
permis de nous souder tout en nous
respectant avec différentes nuances on
est tombé d'accord à l'unanimité sur le
développement des soins palliatifs
partout et pour tous ça c'est indéniable
maintenant et je vais reprendre
également les termes de la commission
temporaire de la fin de vie qui disait
que il était également en plus de la
nécessité de développer des soins
objectifs partout en France d'octroyer
des droits à ceux qui le demandent tout
en respectant les droits des autres ça
c'était important maintenant vous nous
demandiez si nous avions poursuivi nos
missions en tant que membre de la
Convention citoyenne et je dois vous
dire que nous avons fondé deux
associations l'association des 194 et
une autre association
284 également voilà c'est il y a une
association avec des membres extrêmement
investis impliqués également et ça
permet un avis participatif avec des
membres disponibles pour répondre aux
différentes demandes et dans toutes les
régions avoir également des échanges
avec les députés voyez on ne s'arrête
pas on s'investit et les scènes et les
sénateurs pardonnez-moi je ne vous
oublie pas je ne vous oublie pas nous
avons également continuer
nous avons également continué avec
différentes interventions des
conférences débats également dans
différentes structures et notamment des
hôpitaux
j'insiste nous avons également
travaillé sur la journée des droits des
patients les Journées Européennes les
journées des droits en santé où on a pu
mettre en place différents stands par
exemple dans les hôpitaux de la PHP pour
informer promouvoir sensibiliser au
droit des patients notamment sur les
directives anticipées personne de
confiance refuse soin arrêt des
thérapeutiques obstinations des
raisonnables parce qu'il nous apparaît
important que la population française et
notamment les patients parce que ils
sont au cœur
de leur prise en charge et bien
connaissent leurs droits donc moi je
vais parler en mon nom personnel ce que
je retiens de cette expérience c'est
quelque chose de très riche humainement
et émotionnellement qu'on n'oubliera
jamais qu'on n'oubliera jamais et j'ai
je suis particulièrement étonnée du
respect que nous avons eu les uns envers
les autres contrairement à certains
politiques qui n'ont pas forcément les
capacités de s'entendre nous nous sommes
respectés nous avons
respecté les nuances et les avis et les
sensibilités de chacun voilà je vous
remercie infiniment
alors on se calme un peu il reste encore
quelques minutes
on se calme un peu je pense qu'on
travaille nous aussi dans le respect
l'image donnée par l'Assemblée nationale
n'est pas forcément celle du Sénat
oui enfin Madame écoutez vous êtes ici
dans une commission si votre clé
sénateurs se comportement vous avez tout
le loisir de ne pas conclure non c'est
pas ce que je voulais dire non je
voulais vous remercier je voulais
remercier les quatre citoyens qui sont
venus parce qu'ils travaillent voilà et
c'est important pour eux de venir porter
cette parole parce que il y a un travail
remarquable qui a été conduit pendant
quatre mois et donc voilà moi je voulais
vous remercier pour ça je voulais vous
remercier aussi pour votre écoute et
pour vos questions le je crois que pour
répondre à la question pratique donc il
y a bien une indemnité qui est versée
c'est 84 euros net par jour et puis
ensuite il y a une compensation pour
perte de revenus pour les gens qui
travaillent et qui du coup posent des
jours de congés donc ça c'est 11 euros
de l'heure et à ça ça ajoute à ça
s'ajoute pardon un défraiement complet
donc déplacement hébergement frais de
garde d'enfant etc enfin c'est très
important que ces dispositifs ne soient
pas excluant et qui est pas de comment
dire d'inégalité sociale par dessus
voilà donc ça ça c'est un élément
important après pour vous répondre
j'avoue qu'il y a beaucoup de questions
donc j'essaie de vous répondre
rapidement le le moi ce que je retiens
quand même c'est qu'on peut pas sortir
indifférente un exercice démocratique
comme celui-ci et que ce soit sur la fin
de vie ou sur d'autres sujets mais sur
la fin de vie c'est assez parlant quand
on arrive on donne un bout de soi-même
et on prend un bout des autres et ça
c'est quelque chose de profondément
marquant alors pour les citoyens ça
c'est clair vous l'avez vécu mais même
pour nous en tant que comité de
gouvernance en tant qu'equipe
organisatrice on était là tout le temps
et c'est ça moi ça m'a donné vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir en notes
démocratie parce que voilà enfin vous
faites un travail remarquable mais on
sait que les Françaises les Français ont
une défiance quand même assez forte
vis-à-vis des institutions et il me
semble que travailler à des outils pour
les associer davantage pour que la
construction de la décision publique
elle n'appartiennent pas uniquement aux
élus mais qu'elle puisse être aussi
alimentée par des citoyennes des
citoyens à qui on donne des outils à un
moment c'est quelque chose de très
important pour répondre à votre question
sur le travail parlementaire à suivre
vous verrez si vous souhaitez
auditionner ou non des citoyens des
citoyennes mais vous avez quand même 184
citoyens qui ont Bos 27 jours 27 jours
sur la fin de vie ils ont un niveau
d'expertise aujourd'hui qui a un niveau
d'expertise citoyen mais qui est très
au-dessus que la plupart des Françaises
des Français et c'est bien normal parce
qu'a priori on n'est pas tous des
spécialistes de la fin de vie donc ça je
pense que c'était important de le dire
donc ce que je retiens pour vous
répondre c'est ça et un autre élément
que je retiens c'est que il faut pas non
plus faut pas être dans un discours trop
angéliste en fait tout ça c'est
énormément de travail c'est énormément
de travail vraiment que ce soit pour les
citoyens qu'on parte qui ont participé
ou pour les personnes qui ont organisé
cette convention c'est un énorme travail
de mettre en mouvement tous ces gens et
de s'assurer que les choses se passent
au mieux alors je on a des humains en
face de nous et le principe c'est que la
démocratie c'est une matière organique
on peut essayer de tout anticiper on
anticipera jamais tout et donc il y a
parfois des réactions qu'on n'avait pas
anticipées des commentaires des
interventions extérieures intérieures et
donc ça ça nécessite voilà de se
réajuster en permanence mais je crois
que quand on intègre cet élément là et
vous ai donné là et qu'on est prêt à
travailler beaucoup pour vous répondre
je pense que oui la plupart des sujets
peuvent être portés et traités dans le
cadre de ses conventions après mon avis
à moi à titre personnel c'est qu'il y a
deux types de sujets qui peuvent faire
l'objet enfin qui peuvent être
particulièrement intéressants de traiter
dans le cas d'une convention soit des
sujets qui n'ont pas encore été
défricher et pour lesquels on a envie de
voilà de de tester d'interroger les
citoyens des citoyens dans un cadre un
peu spécial soit des sujets sur lesquels
il y a des débats depuis très très très
très longtemps et dans lesquels les
espaces classiques et pour lesquels
pardon les espaces classiques ne
permettent pas
d'avancer alors c'est pas le bon terme
mais voilà je trouve que c'est
intéressant et pour moi faire une
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
c'est une forme de courage politique
d'une certaine manière parce que c'est
accepté à un moment de faire un pas de
côté et de demander à des gens qui ne
représentent que même mais qui vont
travailler de manière exigeante et
remarquable d'aider les décideurs à
construire une réponse politique
exigeante après on en pense qu'on en
pense ça si vous avez bien le droit de
penser ce que vous pensez évidemment
mais je trouve que de ce point donc là
c'est vraiment intéressant à dire et par
rapport aux critiques de certains élus
moi je franchement je veux bien tout
entendre que ce dispositif soit
perfectible qui est des erreurs qui
étaient formulées je réponds à Monsieur
par rapport voilà qui est des erreurs
qui étaient formulées qui a un point
d'amélioration enfin qui est des pistes
d'amélioration c'est une c'est évident
par contre vraiment sous-entendre que
les citoyens ont été manipulés ça je
peux pas le laisser dire parce que c'est
faux vraiment c'est faux d'une part et
d'autre part je trouve que c'est pas
rendre justice à l'intelligence des gens
et dernier point quand même parce qu'on
a quand même fait on a vérifié quand
vous regardez les auditionnez etc le la
proportion des points de vue a été
respectée et les soignants qui disent
qu'ils n'ont pas été assez entendu 3/5
des auditions c'est c'était des
soignants et donc du coup je veux bien
je trouve ça indispensable d'entendre la
parole médicale il y a pas il y a pas de
sujet mais c'est une convention
citoyenne pour poser un débat de société
[Musique]